man 1 19 Emmys as the science guy on PBS
and now he's saving the world streaming
now on netflix season 3 Bill Nye saves
the world and Bill Nye is right here on
the Rich Eisen show good to see you bill
it's so good to be seen you know we just
had a very fun shot on the television
side of things I had no idea you were in
stand-up comedy first that's your those
are your roots on mechanical engineering
first so it's so what would you say is
your your you're an engineer first then
a comedian second absolutely okay you
decided to mix the two when it all came
down to it I was trying to change the
world I got very concerned about the
United States I came of age I'm from the
United States that'll happen it's the
world's third most populous country it's
likely yes
I came of age and we were abandoning
teaching them teaching the metric system
embracing the Ford Pinto the Chevy Vega
and just thought the state of
engineering in the US was in decline I
wanted to get young people excited about
science mm-hmm so that we would have a
scientifically literate voting populous
to make good decisions about for example
the environment going forward so we'll
see what happens
yeah how's that working for you these
days we'll see I'll give you an example
change the subject only a little
confused would the bill there's any
anywhere so people survived getting shot
at at Stoneman Douglas High School
mm-hmm you can tell are very active
they're gonna be politically active and
I think they represent an enormous
cohort as we say in demography and
demographics of elections I think when
those young when people of that age
become voters and captains of industry
things are gonna change
well you know what I find as well I was
kind of joking but not really at the top
of this hour that I always had problem
with that green wedge and Trivial
Pursuit the science question when to
read the dreaded green which I thought
was something like the Seahawks
it could be something on the kick off
special teams but I do now having three
young kids see that their their minds
for science and trying to figure out why
things are and how they come to be
they're fascinated by yes we all are
they are fascinated yes you know so the
question is is how do we when they
become teenagers or adolescents and how
do we continue that so why should want
to build AI saves the world of course
they should watch Bill Nyes saves the
world and turn it up loud but the other
thing is algebra make sure you learn
algebra algebra it turns out to be the
most reliable indicator of whether or
not a person pursues a technical career
it is not obvious that its cause and
effect okay it's not obvious that
algebra causes you to pursue a career in
technical field however it is reasonable
that being able to think abstractly
about numbers enables you to think
abstractly about all sorts of things
well as reasonable it's it has helped me
on occasion fill out a an expense report
yes you know and things like yes plus y
equals the think algebraically at some
point but we it's just a cool thing to
learn Bill Nighy here on the Rich Eisen
show what do you think in sports it has
what which sport do you think involves
the most science or physics to try and
figure out it because obviously
analytics has become so important thing
in a football and basketball baseball
the way the Nightwatchman who started
the sabermetrics guy in Kansas oh it was
uh it was was his Bill of the old Miller
Bill want to look that up right anyway
the thing that makes baseball different
from a lot of other sports is that in
baseball the statistics are very
meaningful if a guy bats 289 he's a
better hitter than a guy who bets 249
but in basketball it's not clear that
the number of field goals missed is as
significant as the number of fouls
called by the refs
well sure I guess we can we can cherry
pick which stat might mean cherry
picking is with all things about is is
which which statistics to pick that's it
and so speaking of whining and
complaining go for the old thing about a
winning pitcher you know that's like a
statistic that intuitively seems like
it's really good but is it I mean if
what if your team doesn't hit what if
your infielders make errors what if well
the wind the wind category in football
that the quarterback has certain amount
of wins
yes Rives the traditionalist nuts that
that is not indicative of of a of a
quarterbacks worth are wins because
there are ten other people that you're
playing offense with an 11 other people
who are on the field when you're not yes
39 isn't it other people is it 40 people
on a football well well yes there's 53
but I understand so it makes a different
special teams for sure so that's what
drives a little bit people nuts but what
about spin rate that's all I'm hearing
about right now run a curve ball or a
fastball that somebody's spin rate is
and then there's exit velocity agent
velocity we love do you believe in this
stuff believe in it yes it's physics
you can't not believe in it no it's
fabulous so you know part of the
evaluation of players yeah becoming
objective twenty years ago
with Bill James and sabermetrics just
revolutionize the game in a cool way but
for me personally it's still a game and
it's still full of rules and that's what
makes it so charming you know it's like
a board game where you're advancing game
pieces around the diamond and that
getting that done Israel is based on
probabilities and skill it's fabulous
well not too up bill nye here on the
Rich Eisen show so you said that you got
started and engineering and Boeing you
worked for Boeing so are you a Seattle
sports fan is that essentially follow
the mirrors and the Seahawks especially
mhm but I grew up in the city of
Washington DC so I'm a Nationals fan I
was a senator's fan
okay and I was there for two of the
games when a player named Frank Howard
oh sure
hit one of or two of his ten home runs
in six games which was a big deal he's a
huge guy six foot seven just smash the
ball way out there before steroids and
so speaking of steroids yes
baseball is a game of rules it's all
this or right we okay if you drop the
third strike the guy could run to first
base if it's unoccupied
hmm okay why did this a rule okay we
have another rule you can't take
steroids well it makes it okay with this
rule no steroids all right fine so why
not just make it a rule which is what
just you can't take steroids
professional baseball I mean it's a
different way of looking so you so
Robinson Cano just got suspended 80
games you bill no I think that that he
should never be able to play baseball
again no 80 games that's like most of
the season or that's half a half the
season yeah it's pretty okay so you
agree with that yeah I mean okay the
parsing the number of games that's
that's we hire people for that so you're
a Nationals fan now yeah yeah you can't
help it okay yeah yeah and Bryce Harper
and those those are your guys pretty
yeah okay so Bill Nye saves the world
season three streaming now on netflix
one of the episodes the one that
fascinates me the most is what is your
pet really thinking well that's about
the nature of consciousness okay so
here's my claim some of my best friends
are dogs good for you maybe really my
only friend is a dog okay maybe but I
don't think that he has thought about
his place in the cosmos the way maybe
you and I have I don't think he has ever
stopped to think about the value of
algebra he may have but it's just not
clear well if he might be figuring out
where his next meal is got well that's a
good question that seems to be
continually honest have any food right
are we going for a walk and then back
there all the time are you another dog
are you a tough are you a dog yes do you
have any food
we're going for a walk you have any food
all right so there's something about
humans that's different from that it's
there's something about us that's
different we think too much maybe my guy
over there any Yankee hats frequently
does he thinks about all day is about
where the next meal is coming and where
what the Yankees are doing it was it 26
rings or some obsession 27 we're talking
science and math I mean you guys quickly
corrected him you guys the pitcher
should bat just does this more
interesting oh okay it's just more
interesting is it really yeah I I grew
up with pitchers batting then I lived in
an American League City for 26 years the
pitcher at the Seattle mirrors I was a
20-game guy I could you can buy 20 games
at a time and okay but it's just more
interesting when the pitcher hits it's
just a little more going on I don't know
I'll take the opposite point of view
which is like when you're playing for 20
games do you want to see Randy Johnson
grab a bat or Edgar Martinez when you
want to see a girl I want to see Randy
freaking try to hit okay because those
guys are universally the best player at
their high school right they were
certainly in the starting team at their
college if they went to college right
and they were pretty good hitters back
then but then when you don't yeah I mean
this is what makes baseball fans crazy
right but it's just the game's more
interesting and due respect I don't mind
fewer home runs when well you can't talk
can you say such a thing it's just it's
a game you're trying to move guys around
but I mean this would makes baseball
people argue but the insufferable nature
of Yankees fans is is universal I don't
know that was the scientific fact well
it's my observation so I've told the
story because we're promoting the
Netflix show yes I told the story a few
days ago but it's worthy of retelling go
for it I was in the bleachers of the old
Yankee Stadium yes just because I was in
town just doing the Science Guy show we
were in New York the crew we were in New
York
bowtie on you have the whole no no I was
stressed for a baseball game which
included sunglasses and baseball hat
okay
but today the Yankees are playing the
Baltimore Orioles which is a team in
Baltimore this and a woman that you
would describe as grandmotherly gets up
in the bleachers with a cowbell right
and I know that or you'll suck Hank
Boston sucks you suck everybody sucks
Wow okay so the grandmother is leading
the crowd in this cheer and because the
Baltimore Orioles are the opposition
that day they've start with the Orioles
suck but before they go any farther the
Yankee fans want to remind the world
that Boston also sucks and then and then
it turns out that this sort of mystic
view of life you suck in fact really
everybody sucks it's just such a
cheerless view of life but that's worthy
of it's worthy of ridicule I had no idea
that the Yankees needed more cowbell and
then season 4 streaming when it happens
Bill Nye saves the world he will find
this elderly lady a lot more power to
her and she was she was a leader and
disproved that the rest of the world she
was inspirational everybody cheered with
her good to see you bill no it's great
man that was really fun come back
anytime
Josie accion ATS and go caps I gotta say
go cap yeah there you go
Bill Nye here on the Rich Eisen show her
package 60 seconds the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience